Welcome. I am Iana Fortuna, a product
manager in Aessa. And today we're going
to dive into a topic that I personally
find uncomfortable, but which most
probably development teams considered
already solved. The topic is called
architecturally ready, behaviorally
unvalidated. And today with me I have
Yana Gita who is an AI architect and who
claims that you can technically build
systems that are flawless but still have
them fail tremendously in production. So
Yana welcome and tell us more. Hello
Yana. Yes that is right and I would add
something uh in here. It does not just
happen that it will uh it can fail. It
will really fail. Yeah. quite
predictably. In fact, and that is the
part that surprised me the most when I
started to work with aic systems in
production. It is not about not knowing
how to build. It is about the fact that
what you have built has not been
validated for what it is about to
encounter out there. Okay. But before we
dive deeper, why is it behaviorally
unvalidated and not just simply
untested?
>> Tested means you have run a set of
scenarios. Yeah. And probably you passed
that scenarios because this is why you
are in production. Behaviorally
unvalidated means something different.
It means you have not verified how the
system behaves when the real world
scenarios um are not following your test
cases. Yeah. And um this is happening
when a user does something with did not
anticipate. When an input comes in a
format that you were not modeling when a
technically correct decision it's wrong
from business perspective. So testing
verifies what you have thought of and
behaviorally validation verifies what
you do not think of.
Okay. So I'm a product manager right? So
let us start with the why. Let's say you
have the system, you have the
architecture, you have the pipelines,
you have the deployment.
What is missing?
>> What is missing is validation of what I
call the gray zone. Yeah. Look in
traditionally software development you
have a relatively clear line.
Development, testing, production. Super
easy. Yeah. In Aentic AI, there is an
intermediate zone. the zone between
product testing and development where
the truly dangerous things are happening
and it is a zone that very few are
willing to step into because they are
considering it just development. Yeah.
Evaluations.
>> Okay. So why is that?
>> Because it involves a type of work that
do not easily recognize as work on the
product side on the testing side. Yeah.
like I said is purely development and it
is not it is not just code. Um
it is not an automated test. Yeah. Um it
is not a Jet. It is a conversation
between product owner developers and
someone from the business side. Um where
you ask what happens when the agent
receives something that we do not think
of? And the honest answer most of the
time it's we do not know we did not
model that scenarios and this is the
problem.
>> Okay. But isn't that called insufficient
testing?
>> No. And that is the important
distinction. We are calling them
evaluations. Everyone knows them like
this. Um let me give you a concrete
example. We have um a communication
agent. Yeah. And in the beginning it
processed the conversation generated
structure response in a JSON format.
During testing hundreds of conversation
everything worked perfectly in
production. After few weeks parsing
errors starting appearing. Why? Because
real users
typed long conversation, emojis,
multiple languages, it was a combination
of basically everything. Even if we
evaluated it,
>> we were evaluating them separately and
exactly this this was the problem. Um
the model was doing what it was told to
do. It was a lack of behavioral
validation. So we had not verified how
the system reacts to the real complexity
from the real world.
>> And is there anything that could have
been done to avoid these issues from
happening in production?
>> Yes, behavioral evaluations on input
variability. So specifically a set of
evaluations with real world messages
long multilingual with emojis with
chaotic structure where you are not
checking whether the agent response but
whether the output it's structurally
valid yeah so can the JSON be parsed is
the schema respected are the required
fields really present so these are not
unit tests uh these are evaluations that
simulate what the agent actually
encounters in production and you build
them together with product people with
business people with testers because
they know what a real user looks like.
We will come back to to evaluations in
in our discussion. they are the bridge
that ties um everything
even if we are discussing um re related
to behaviorals or with reactions of of
the agents.
>> So what I hear is that the system it's
not poorly built. It's just that it
doesn't mirror the real world scenario
and what happens in reality actually.
>> Exactly. And that is frustrating because
the engineering team did evaluations,
did testing, did everything perfectly.
Yeah. But actually it was not so
perfectly because not they were not
taking the time to ask what does the
agent do when it receives something
completely unexpected? And the implicit
answer from the product side, from the
development side, was it will probably
figure it out. Oh yeah, spoiler alert,
it's not figuring it out. You mentioned
something interesting a few days ago.
Um, you said that a system can still
fail and this failure can be invisible
from a monitoring and infrastructure
perspective. So, how does that look in
practice?
>> Yeah, this means that your dashboard is
green. Yeah, latency is fine. Zero
errors. Respond code 200. Okay. And yet
the business level at the business level
something it's fundamentally wrong. Let
me give you an example that frustrate me
a lot. Um an assessment agent. Yeah. It
uh talked to candidates um evaluate
responses. At one point the candidate
was uh giving an completely unexpected
answer. The agent attempt to an action
that did not exist and the orchestrator
caught that exception, executed a fall
back and continued. From a technical
perspective, it was flawless. Um the
candidate was looped for 40 minutes in
the assessment and we received the
feedback from his side not from the
monitoring system.
>> Oh wow. But doesn't that mean that you
have just insufficient monitoring?
>> Not necessarily insufficient but
insufficient calibrated in agentic
systems. Observability does not mean
logging actions. It means logging the
reasoning what the agent observed, what
plan it formed, why it choose action X
instead of action W. So why not only log
actions?
>> Because you will see that everything
went fine. Green dashboard, zero errors.
But if you log the reasoning, you see
that the agent made a decision based on
a scenario that nobody had anticipated.
And the difference between the two is
the difference between a system you
control and one that merily appears to
be working.
>> That sounds like an enormous volume of
logging. Is that technically feasible?
>> You do not need to log everything. You
log at the checkpoints. So think of it
into this way. If we have an agentic
flow from with 10 to 15 steps, you do
not need logging at every step. You need
it at the decision points where the
agent choose a pet not where it simply
execute an instruction and you need an
end to end trace ID that allows you to
reconstruct the entire decision chain
after the fact that is not an
implementation detail. It is the minimum
requirement for an agentic system in
production. So let's talk more about
this gray zone that you call behavioral
validation. You mentioned that it sits
at the crosswalk between products
definition, product testing and product
development. Um who is responsible for
it?
>> Everyone. And that is the problem.
>> Okay. Traditionally development builds,
testers tests and uh product defines.
Yeah. In aentic AI, those boundaries no
longer hold clearly. And I will let you
know why. Because an agent is not just
code. It is code that makes decisions.
And um those decisions
must be validated not just technically
but also semantically and from a
business perspective. And no single team
can do that alone.
>> Okay. So as a product manager that
sounds great in theory but in practice
how do I convince a developer to sit in
the same room with myself and somebody
from the business side to discuss
behavioral evaluations?
You show them why it is necessary and
the best argument it's a real failure.
We had a situation with an agent that
was producing strategic decisions for
manufacturing.
It correctly detected a major anomaly, a
significant spike in the data. Yeah, it
labeled it correctly. Everything was
technically perfect. And uh the problem
for that specific label, there was no
decision fallback. Nobody had modeled
the scenario. The downstream agent, the
one making the strategic decisions,
received a valid label for which it had
no instruction and it made the decision
a decision in order in the order of
hundreds of millions of euros. It was
strategically completely wrong. But it
was not a bug. It was not a
hallucination. It was a lack of
behavioral modeling, a real scenario
that nobody had anticipated
>> and who should have anticipated that
scenario.
>> This is a key question and the answer is
the team not one person and that is why
I insist on crossf functional
collaboration. The solution of this
issue or this uh bug let's say it's the
agent orchestration flow. The complete
flow of decisions that an agent or a
system of agents uh makes must be built
with the rigor of a contract and it's a
flow contract. It's not um technical
artic art artifact. It's a product
artifact. Business people know which
scenarios are critical. Product people
know um what experience it's acceptable.
developers know how to uh we what is
technically fasible and the testers know
how to find the gaps. So if you do not
have all of them to the same table in
the same room, you will always have
blind spots.
>> Okay. So what's the role of an architect
in this whole landscape? Am I guessing
it right that the architect is playing
the role of a facilitator in this
scenario?
>> Yes. In 2026, the AI architect is not um
in place just to draw diagrams. Yeah. So
the the role is more complex because you
need to bring the people to the same
table and to discuss what it really
matters to connect the dots. The
question it's very important how you ask
the correct questions. Yeah. So instead
of asking how to build something an
application an agentic system something
that you can find out on the internet
very easily and with a little bit of
practice you will know what to choose.
The correct uh question is more like
what we are expecting from this agent
when something goes wrong or fails or
it's not as not in acceptance criteria
let's say. Yeah, you understood right.
>> You mentioned principles. So let's get
specific. What principles do you apply?
>> Yes, I have a few that I have learned
even into the hard way. So uh the most
important for me always design for
failure. Um
remember that the failure is never a
single event. In an agentic system, the
worst case scenario is not a failed uh
request. It's a chain of wrong decisions
each build on the previous one. Each
amplifying the error before it. And uh
an agent does not fail in isolation. An
agent it's failing in cascade.
>> That sounds alarming. So how do you
contain that cascading
>> through boundaries
>> and that leads to the second principle
that I have clearly define what is input
data, what are the instructions and
where the boundaries are. An agent
operates within um three spaces. What is
told to do, what is what received as
data and what is forbidden from doing.
When you blur those uh spaces,
the most serious problems emerge.
Blur them. How? Who blurs them?
Sometimes we do as a team, but sometimes
someone else um does it uh deliberately
and uh that is less obvious uh part when
external data can contain in
instructions. an email, a document, a
web page, even advertising. Um, anything
that enter everything that enters uh in
the agent context can be intentionally
crafted to alter its behavior. It is
called prompt injection. Everyone knows
about it. It's not theoretically. It's
real. It's in production and it's
various.
And how do you prepare the system for
scale in this case? Because we are
talking about multiple agents and
multiple possible failure points, right?
>> Yes. This is uh the third principle.
Basically I I stress constantly
multi-agent increase complexity
exponentially and uh before you add
another agent you really need to know if
the that agent that new agent it's
mandatory maybe a normal workflow or uh
a backend solution it's enough. Yeah. So
we are not adding multiple agents if are
not really um mandatory. Every new agent
is an additional point of failure, a
source of latency and um an entity that
can make decisions that contradict the
rest of the of the system.
>> Okay. But however, we are moving into
multi- aent setups, environments,
spaces.
>> Yes.
>> Right. Yes. And I'm not so saying you
should not uh use them. Yeah. Um I'm
saying you should be aware of what you
are taking on when you have multiple
agents the agent orchestration flow
grows not exponentially but grows a lot.
And for now we are not able every time
to stay in the same room to collaborate
and of course you need to take this into
consideration. Um each agent has an own
decision, its own states, its own
failure nodes. The the combinations uh
explode. That is why I insist that the
flow must be treated as a contract
built, validated and signed by the
entire team. It is the only way of
capturing the complexity.
You mentioned something interesting
earlier. uh you said that an agent
doesn't know what it does not know. So
can you expand on that?
>> Yes, maybe is the most underestimated
aspect. Unlike a human who senses
uncertainty, a language model produce
output with the same fluency and the
same confidence tone regardless of
whether it has a solid information or
just making things up. And uh there is
no natural signal for I do not know. So
you as the architect need to define when
the agent must uh stop and ask for
clarification. We are using basically a
tool inside the pro prompt request
clarification. Yeah, you explicitly
instruct. It is better to ask than to
guess. That's it. So sounds simple in
practice. It's easy. Um, but it's easy
also to forget or to um
to say it's too hard to to test. Okay,
I'm smiling because I'm just remembering
about the question about how many Rs are
in strawberry. So, yeah. Um, but what
you said um sounds quite difficult to
test. So, how do you test it? Because,
uh, from my point of view, it doesn't
fit into a unit test.
>> It does not. And uh this brings uh us
back to the importance of crossf
functional collaboration. Product people
know um what questions the agent should
be asking. Developers know how uh to
implement the the mechanism and the
testers know how to simulate the
uncertainty. uh so no one of from these
perspectives can um or it's sufficient
on on its own and this validation is not
one um time effort um it is continuous
as as you discover new scenarios in
production almost each mount I will I
will not say each day I was thinking
about every day
so let us Take one step back. Let's say
somebody who is listening right now is
at the stage of building an MVP uh for
an agentic system. What would be top
three things that they need to keep into
account while building it?
First, do not wait for production to
discover how your agent uh behaves. Put
it in front of real users as fast as
possible. 10 users are enough. You don't
need more. You don't need it to make it
at scale.
10 users will you will find more from
them than from 500 tests. Yeah. So it's
really a game changer. Second um build
semantic fallbacks uh mechanism not just
technical ones. Yeah. It is not enough
to catch um the exception and retry. You
need to define what the agent does when
it receives something valid but
unexpected.
Exception caught fallback executed. The
conversation continues sounds great but
in a log. Um if the user is stuck for 40
minutes in a loop you have a business
problem not an infrastructure one.
>> And the third the agent state lives
outside the model. An LLM it's stateless
by the nature. If progress intermediate
decisions and relevant context leave
only in the prompt they will be lost or
disorted over time. So you need an
external state store. Um and you need to
save the progress at every important
checkpoint. Otherwise um I like to say
that you will have an amnesiac with
permissions.
>> An amnesiac with permissions. That's
quite vivid.
>> Yes. But it's accurate. So an agent that
does doesn't know what has done and has
permissions to execute to keep acting.
It's exactly that. It's an amnesiac with
permissions.
>> All right. Um so to summarize up until
now, right, we talked about how to
design, how to think, what to do at MVP
stage. Now if we are to think about
behaviorally validating
all of these aspects, how do you do
that? How do you measure it? Also
>> hopefully everyone knows the the good
answer from the technical side. Yeah. So
I'm talking here about evaluations um
evolves
and this is the loop that close
everything we have um just discussed all
of this crossf functional work the
conversations with the business the
scenarios from uh the product the edge
cases discovered in in production does
not stay on a whiteboard it turns into
concrete evaluations every behavioral
scenario you identify becomes um an eval
that you run, measure and track over
time.
So aren't eval just tests then?
>> Not in the traditional sense. A
technical test verifies did the agent
return a valid JSON? Yes. No. Yeah. A
behav behavioral evol verifies did the
agent make the right decision in this
specific context. Did it know when to
stop? Did it ask for clarification when
it should uh have did it stay aligned
with the original objective after 15
steps? Yeah. So these are the things you
cannot verify with a unit test. Um and
those scenarios come exactly from the
collaboration we have been talking about
today. In practice the process looks
like you collaborate cross functional to
identify what you should be validating.
You turn those scenarios into evals. You
run the evals continuously uh not once
but at every iteration. Yeah. every
model change, every prompt modification
that you have um done that is the bridge
that is how you go from I hope it works
to I know it works and I can prove it
and this is also one of the way into
which you can give the assurance. Yeah.
Agent insurance. Can you insure an agent
and what's the relationship between
insurance agent insurance actually and
evals?
>> Yes. So what we are making normally with
evaluations we are controlling we are
giving the stability and the speed of
our agents. Yeah we are controlling
them. Um now there is uh this
certifications of the agents of of the
companies that are producing uh agents.
Yeah. And what is required? Risk
quantification, predictability and
audit. How you are giving this with
evaluations. Not the only thing yeah
required for the certification but three
very important characteristics
with which you can ensure that your
agent it's doing something specifically.
>> That's very interesting. This sounds
like the next step in the evolution of a
gentic systems.
>> Yes. Um we invent them, we build them,
we scale them and now we are ensuring
that they are making what are supposed
to do. Okay. So looks like we've got a
lot of work to do. Now the question is
when and how will we achieve it? I'm
talking about that big amount of work
that we need to do in order to really
build robust agentic systems.
>> Yes. When each day Yeah. Uh with what
we are using AI tools and uh I'm happy
to say that sometimes we receive a help
or uh we improve our pace with even
50%age. Sometimes it's not 50 can be a
30. It's the most common let's say but
with really difficult uh things or
complex better to say things to
implement um even with 10%age uh we are
happy. It's a help that it's required
because exactly like you said the amount
of work the amount of things that almost
each day we need to come back and to add
and not because the system was not
correct but for the system to be correct
also in the future in the near future.
the things are evolving into oh yeah the
pace it's incredible I'm I'm very happy
actually that I'm living this this
period yeah
>> so uh we are coming to an end uh but
Dana if you had to leave the audience
with some thoughts what would those be
>> technically we can build anything almost
anything right now that is no longer the
the challenge the challenge is that what
we have built beh behave correctly when
we plan uh no longer holds and um you do
not learn that from uh the architecture,
you do not learn it from uh the
pipelines or um you don't learn it from
the green dashboards. You learn it only
by putting the agent in front of reality
and having the right people in the room
when things breaks and even better if
it's possible before the things to
break.
>> So what if that doesn't happen?
>> They have ancient permissions um in
production and they will find out from
from their users um not from their
monitoring. I really hope that we are
improving the way in which we are using
the evaluations. Everyone is doing them,
don't get me wrong. But there is a super
super fine line between just having
evaluations and having the correct ones.
>> I see. So perhaps some closing thoughts
here would be that perhaps everyone
should think about what questions to ask
their agent.
>> Yes,
>> you Thank you very much. Thank you,
Yana.